Nili Gilbert: The reality is that while
financial capital has been moving
towards addressing the climate transition,
it’s not moving fast enough,
and it’s not moving
at the scale that we need.
So it's really great
to be here with you today
to talk about why
we think that's happening,
what we think some of the challenges are
and how to address it.
So what are you seeing?
David Blood: Well, maybe we'll start
with a little bit of background.
The United Nations estimates
that we will need something in the order
of three to four trillion dollars per year
to globally decarbonize
our economy through 2050.
This shift -- and I know
you’ve talked about this as well --
will be the most significant shift
in economic history.
We think it will be more extensive
than the industrial revolution
and probably faster
than the digital revolution.
And the good news is we are seeing
funds flowing to climate solutions.
The different news is that,
as you said, it's not nearly enough.
It's not going
to the hard-to-abate sectors.
And importantly, it is not going
to the Global South.
In fact, we think that we will likely miss
every single one of the 17
Sustainable Development Goals.
We’ve been at this problem
for almost 20 years,
and we've seen
enormous incremental change.
But we need now transformational
change in our economies,
in our businesses
and our financial institutions.
NG: Why has this been so hard?
DB: Well, it's a good question,
and it's complicated for one thing.
But I think there's probably
four fundamental points.
The first is the finance
sector is critical,
but it does rely on businesses
and entrepreneurs to lead the way.
We are financing their ideas
and their businesses.
Secondly, we do need change
in public policy
and change in regulation.
Thirdly, with the investment community,
we don't yet have the tools
to truly evaluate
whether a company or an industry
is decarbonizing.
We're making progress,
but there's still work that we need to do.
And lastly, we need
to fundamentally change
the way people think
about capital allocation.
And by that, we mean
we need to create the capabilities
for investors to understand
the impact of their investments
within a traditional
risk and return framework.
NG: All of this sounds really challenging.
Is there any good news?
DB: There is. And we're both optimists.
NG: That's right.
DB: That's a good thing.
A good place to be.
First of all, there’s no question
there’s enough capital.
There's something in the order
of 150 trillion dollars of institutions
who've committed to net zero.
Now, we know that that's an overstatement,
but the point is 150 trillion,
100 trillion, that's a lot of money.
We have the money to make the transition.
Secondly, there are no legal barriers --
we'll come back to this in a little bit --
for investors to allocate capital
to sustainable solutions.
Thirdly -- and we're seeing it yesterday,
we're seeing it today --
there are amazing entrepreneurs,
amazing business people,
and the technology cost downcurves
are happening even as we speak.
And as Al [Gore] mentioned yesterday,
public policy is also on the move.
We have seen the Inflation Reduction Act.
It is the most significant
climate legislation in the United States
and indeed probably the world.
And the Europeans
are responding aggressively
to decarbonize their economy
because of the tragic war in Ukraine.
And lastly, as we both know,
finance can change.
When my dad was a portfolio manager
at Ford Motor Company
in the late 60s, early 70s,
the way he made investments
was based upon limiting risk.
That was their job.
But then as time went on,
people began to realize
that if you could be paid for risk,
perhaps that would be
a better way to deploy capital.
And so whole industries developed,
like the venture capital industry,
like the growth equity industry
and, of course,
the high-yield marketplace.
So finance can change,
and that's going to be a very important
part of the of the solution.
Now we've been talking
about sort of the macro picture.
You're working on the ground.
What are you seeing?
NG: Well, you know,
one of the reasons that I think
that the finance pathway
towards net zero is so challenging
is because it touches every other pathway,
because finance encompasses
the whole global economy.
And so the finance transition
means supporting the transitions
of individual sectors
of every country
and always paying attention
to the needs of individual communities
as we get this done.
But while we're doing
and supporting this work on the ground,
our pathway still has to add back up
to a Paris-aligned pathway
at the end of the day.
And so bringing together
this top-down and bottom-up effort
is extremely challenging.
But I think that the energy sector itself,
which as you know,
is in many ways the other key sector
for driving the transition,
provides a really good example
of this framework in practice.
So the International
Energy Agency, the IEA,
has told us that, as of last year,
finance for clean energy is actually equal
with finance for fossil fuels,
which sounds like good news, right?
But the challenge is that by 2030,
we actually need finance for clean energy
to reach four times what's going
into traditional fossil fuels.
So we need massive scale,
massive change in a short amount of time,
and we need even more than that
to go into financing transitions
for individual sectors on the ground,
for breaking down the demand
for fossil fuels
as a way ultimately
to break down the supply.
So when you think
about these three buckets,
limiting finance for fossil fuels,
scaling up finance for clean energy
and then investing
to end the demand for fossil fuels,
I actually think that one
of the greatest untapped --
it’s being tapped, but one of the greatest
forward-looking opportunities
is actually in that third bucket,
where we break down the demand.
And when we think about that bucket,
one of the places where we need
to act much more quickly
is in focusing on hard-to-abate sectors.
These are the most
energy-intensive sectors
that won't be able to run
on solar and wind.
Things like cement,
steel, aviation, shipping,
which actually make up almost
a third of global emissions in total.
So we really need to work
to address these.
But the good news is that we actually
have a lot of the solutions
to be able to get these sectors
to their goals.
And thanks to policy,
thanks to rising demand
for these solutions,
bringing down their costs,
and thanks to technological improvements,
we now see that the cost
for the clean solutions is approaching,
or in some cases is even lower than,
the costs for the
high-emitting alternatives.
So what finance needs to do
is partner with science,
continue to engage with policy
and work with engineers
to be able to bring these solutions
online at scale.
DB: Well, we agree with you
about the hard-to-abate sectors.
Do you have any favorite
ones to talk about?
(Laughter)
NG: Well, I can't play favorites.
DB: But if you were ...
NG: But one sector that
I'm really excited about right now
is aviation,
because sustainable aviation
looks ready to scale.
One of the things that we're seeing is
that there's a rising amount
of corporate demand
to buy sustainable aviation fuel,
which is the key unlock
for decarbonizing this sector.
But what we're also seeing
is that the supply
of sustainable aviation fuel
is not nearly enough to meet that demand
or to meet the goals for the sector,
even for 2030.
Forget about 2040 or 2050.
And so what we need to do
to make a difference here
is focus on multiple production pathways
for sustainable aviation fuel.
Today, most of the fuel
is being produced using biofuels,
which just isn't fit to scale.
So what we need to do
is look at pathways which exist.
Like we can make this fuel out of ethanol,
we can make it out of carbon,
even carbon dioxide
that's been captured from the atmosphere.
We can make this stuff
out of municipal solid waste,
not to be trashy.
(Laughter)
And so the example of aviation shows a map
for how finance needs to partner
with individual sectors to get this done.
Yes, we need to invest with airlines
and give them long-term capital
to achieve their goals.
But also separately, we need to invest
in the solutions that they need
to reach those goals.
And I think that the aviation sector
also paints a picture
of where we need to go
in this transition as a whole,
why it’s hard and why I’m optimistic.
Because the truth is that there is a lot
that we're going to have to let go
in this transition,
and that's challenging.
We need to do it in a just way.
But the other truth is
that there's also so much
that we get to create.
We need to let go of jet fuel,
but we also get to invest
in all of these sustainable fuels.
So what I see is a massive
multigenerational opportunity for growth,
sustainable growth.
Just imagine creating a transition
that is greater in scale
than the industrial revolution
to be delivered in less than 30 years.
It's an unprecedented
opportunity for impact.
So I'm excited.
I don't know, David.
Do you think that we can do this?
DB: Well, we both are optimists.
And I think we both have said
it's going to be difficult,
but we can do it.
We need transformational change
in our industries,
in our financial institutions,
in civil society
and certainly in public policy.
But we have to remember and understand,
and we're seeing it very vividly now,
the impacts of climate change
are with us now
and will get more accelerated
over the course
of the next couple of years.
Al [Gore] and I published an op-ed
in the “Wall Street Journal”
in November of last year
talking about fiduciary duty.
And let us be very clear:
investors who do not consider climate
are running significant risks
in their portfolios
and are not fulfilling
their fiduciary duty.
(Applause)
A pensioner living
in a 5.5-degree Fahrenheit --
as opposed Celsius --
5.5-degree Fahrenheit world
with degraded biosystems
and rampant inequality
will not enjoy the fruits
of their retirement.
Now we know finance can change.
It's not static.
We believe very strongly
that the role of finance
is to provide the means for society
to achieve its ambitions.
And the good news is
climate-led investing is happening.
It is becoming an asset class.
And so by creating situations
where capital markets
can expand what they value,
to take account of sustainability impacts,
will allow us as investors
to, in fact, provide the means
for society to achieve its objectives
on the planet, on people and on nature.
NG: Sounds good.
I say let's go out there and do it.
Thank you, David.
Thank you.
(Applause)